marie pierre vincent s'occupe de ces
cinquante vaches une routine qu'elle
fait plusieurs fois par jour depuis cinq
ans mais depuis quelques semaines
s'appelle est plus lourde c'est la
nourriture baisser quelque chose qui
n'est plus capable de faire je peux la
faire une fois par jour le mais avant ça
je le faisais trois quatre fois mais
même en effet rendu provenant des
enseignes de 34 semaines de la petite
flavie marie-pierre et la seule
propriétaire de sa ferme laitière
tous les jours elle accomplit des tâches
qui met sa santé et celle de son bébé à
risque la médecin qui assure son suivi
de grossesse l'a bien avertis ça faisait
vraiment on n'a pas
été un mystère elle m'a dit que je
devrais pas piqué peut conseiller du
tout puisque c'était mon choix sauf que
c'est d'un côté c'était amy récupérer le
d'enfance quotas pour vous moi
physiquement que ma grossière elle a dû
faire appel à un travailleur étranger
pour l'appuyer dans les tâches devenus
trop difficile pour elle
christiane un colosse originaire du
guatemala qui a été surpris par le défi
physique du travail dans une ferme
laitière
ce travailleur elle doit le payer à même
les charges de sa ferme et elle n'a pas
le choix de le faire elle a un statut de
travailleuse autonome donc elle n'a pas
droit au retrait préventif mais à son
avis le cas des agricultrices
propriétaire devrait être traitée
différemment
on s'en va
le conseil du statut de la femme s'est
penché sur les difficultés des femmes en
agriculture
le conseil propose notamment d'élargir
les critères pour permettre à davantage
de femmes d'avoir accès au retrait
préventif la directrice de la recherche
au conseil raconte que les règles
actuelles créent parfois des situations
paradoxales entre les agricultrices
propriétaires et leurs employés sont
employés qui est salarié bénéficie du
programme pour une maternité sans danger
et donc n était pas en mesure de
réaliser certaines tâches mais cette
tâche lui incombait donc à la
propriétaire qui elle-même intéressante
et qui mettait sa propre santé celle de
son enfant à naître
en afrique
le conseil estime que le projet de loi
59 qui vise à moderniser le régime de
santé et de sécurité du travail aurait
été une belle occasion d'élargir la
portée du programme mais le projet de
loi a été adoptée le 30 septembre
sans les modifications demandées par les
agricultrices et le conseil
de toute façon marie pierre a déjà un
plan pour garder ses bêtes et ses
finances en santé qui est à accepter
quelques risques sur sa propre santé
elle est aussi bien conscient du défi
qui l'attend quand ça flavie viendra au
monde
loue et soul profitent des derniers
jours sur leur immense terrain de jeu la
ferme maraîchère familiale a été vendu
dans deux semaines la famille déménage
et abandonne laventure de produire des
paniers de légumes biologiques les
parents ne voit plus comment ils peuvent
élever des enfants et faire pousser des
légumes en même temps ces lézards de
travail sont un peu folle et on commence
très tôt ont fini très tard ou personnes
qui travaillent à
5,9 cet horaire dictée par les besoins
de la ferme pesait déjà sur leurs
épaules la grossesse surprise de
marie-eve les a poussés à agir ils ont
essayé de trouver un modèle qui leur
permettrait d'alléger leur vie
engagement communautaire entraide entre
les agriculteurs
rien n'a réussi à enlever ce poids de
leurs épaules 10 pour ça aussi qu'on
arrête c'est pour prendre un temps de
réflexion un temps d'arrêt pour ce job
afrique quand on est dedans mais on
n'arrive pas à réfléchir ton n'arrive
pas à penser à aux solutions en
attendant de trouver leur solution
marie-eve et francis se prépare à
laisser cette terre qui l'ont nourri et
aimés pendant des années
ils mettent leurs souvenirs et leur vie
dans des boîtes ils vont ensuite
ralentir et accueillir leur nouveau bébé
ici sophie bernier radio-canada saint
chrysostome